tires
this time we'll call the order of the
as the chair of the criminal justice
public safety committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the over
focus 19 pandemic
and in accordance with household 67 in
the governance emergency board number 12
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to move in tournament
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
and scheduled in the house calendar
today executive session
may be held by any bill report referred
to
referred to the committee please note
that there's no physical location for
members of the public to observe
and listen to contemporaries at this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i confirm
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaries
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries who listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar of the general
website
the notice of this meeting comprised
with house rule
house rules and rsa 91-8 anyone who has
a problem
accessing me should call 271-3600
or email hcs lag.state.gov
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled please note that all
votes that are
taken during the meeting will be done by
a roll call
let's start the main by taking a roll
call attendance
each member states their presence please
also state whether there's anyone in the
room
with you during this meeting which is
thanks chairman welch yeah
representative bob green
here representative hopper here
representative
here representative wallace
representative testerman here
representative true
president representative craft
representative marston
the clerk is president representative
harriet gathright president
are you present can you say yes she's
waving
i don't think she can hear us
representative pantovakis
we'll come back come back okay
representative massimella
here representative bordenay
here alone by myself representative muse
in my office representative newman
i'm here at home and my wife is in
another room
representative andrew bolden i'm here in
the committee room
representative conley i'm here
my wife and kids are in the house but
not present in the room
representative klein knight i'm here
and my family's in other rooms i'm alone
in this room
representative abbott chairman the chair
is president
she was turning into them let me stop
she
no we can hear her that she can't hear
us
as a host can't you just unmute her
she is unmuted and not no i
have the hosts unable to make numbers
representative just so you know
representative burt is not
present today so you are we don't have
any members of the public existing
so she thinks we're we have her music i
just have a split tonight i mean myself
but
so her volume on her computer might be
well while we're dealing with that
technical difficulty uh representative
marston will be recognized at least in
the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty
[Music]
represent gathering you recognize we're
asking for a moment of sign
silence for uh andrew o'hara who lost
moment
this is a pre-hearing announcement and
uh
while we try to address representative
boxes
remember
yes representative pantalakis can you
just confirm that you were here for the
roll call record
[Music]
the device must be muted or turned off
with a
audio feedback
now consider turning off your videos you
intend to use the keyboard for taking
notes
that will also prevent the clicking of
the keyboard
is what uh is being fed back in the
devices this is just what i've been
being reported but the sound quality is
important for
members to speak clearly be mindful of
the location of the microphones
at the same time be aware that most
parts to run the microphone will pick up
every sound we care about side
conversations
those will also be picked up in the
background
uh i will also say that if you are
shuffling papers or whatever the mic you
know just the electrical will take that
noise up
and remembers the public complaint if
they have a difficult time
hearing us the sign-in sheet will stop
accepting new entries for those who wish
to speak at 8am we're not we're not
we don't have any members of the public
testifying thing today the committee
hearing if you sign in
at that time the committee will not have
your name before then however the chair
will provide an opportunity to speak uh
after all registered names are called
at all times raise your hand and be
recognized the science sheet will close
the purpose of questioning your
at this time we will now open the
executive session
my understanding is an amendment that
will be offered that will be amendment
of
2021-1 5498
the members in the room have a copy of
see the members participating remotely
to share the uh the amendment number
2021-1549 one on each
at this time the chair recognizes
representative rose to make the motion
thank you mr chairman yes i make a
motion of ought to pass amendment
two zero two one one five four nine
each so you're making a motion about the
past and then you're offering an
amendment
yeah yeah is there a second step
that motion has been seconded by
representative pratt and i used to offer
that's just for the record two zero two
one dash one
five four nine eight right that is
representative green did you second that
motion representing the second
mr chairman to yield for you to um talk
that's our problem so with this
amendment
first of all just to clarify the
underlying senate bill of 92 that was
presented to the committee
um in addition to having sections on
bail he'd have a
section on involving background checks
to the mark
law enforcement officer he was being
hired and also had a section on
vandalism or instructional property
those sections have been stripping uh
respect
to candidates for uh to be hired
as a police officer this party uh we
passed senate bill
i believe the house bill 530
and that was also passed in the senate
so
there was no under any circumstance
there was no need to pass the same
section
twice so that
i will check the docket right now i
don't know the status of that i know
it was voted on my incentive for
the recognition pass so that should be
on its way at some point to the
corner off of the executive office for
uh consideration
so with respect to what this what this
change is and i'll focus on section
a1 and you see that there's a series of
lists of expenses that are listed there
what is consistent with these offenses
and although
they vary between murder rape sexual
assault
different forms of battery and child
pornography
they all involve a crime against an
individual person as opposed to
a crime against a property or a white
collar crime
what it does it changed it from being a
72 hours
being held for up to 72 hours excluding
weekends and holidays
you then have the entertainment or the
bail commission hearing what this does
is it lowered that for 24 to 36 hours
the 36 hours would be ineffective
depending on when the arrest itself is
made
the problem with that is if someone's
arrested around eight nine o'clock in
the morning on a weekday
they may not make the court in time to
be arraigned that day so that's why you
change it for 36 hours for the members
on the committee
uh who served in the committee last term
we had a similar issue where
[Music]
a person they may not be from a time
perspective
if they're processing the person while
they're in custody
these violent offenses and crimes
against individuals
and also who's felony use for firearm
under sex rsa
650-8 on cold war
it would be 24 hours excluding weekends
and holidays
the courts are not open on the weekend
so if you were arrested on saturday
there's not much that can be done with
respect to that
unless we have the courts open on the
weekend which i don't believe anyone's
advocate
i under the current law it this is that
is consistent with how the war is today
with the irs on the weekend the report's
not open there are circumstances where
you would be
held uh the next
next day the court is over if you are
charged one of these
violent offenses or crimes against the
person
you would go directly you have an
arraignment before the court as opposed
to
a hearing book without the bail
commission
and that person would have
could be retained uh detained if
the the uh the state isn't able to make
a demonstration by clear and convincing
evidence
that by releasing the person they posing
danger to themselves
or to any member of the public including
these residents
so by being charged with one of these
there's no uh consumptive burden
on our at the person being charged
that's not common
it's going to fall on the individual
who's been charged
and if that's it's going to be some
fallen state
the state would have to present evidence
why they feel someone
committed or charges that offense to
remain together
it can also if a person is then held
under that paragraph
meaning the state would have to meet
their burden for proof that the person
poses a danger to themselves
the individual does have a right to
request a subsequent hearing that
is under romanian four remember four
would allow the defendant to then call
they would be able to present any
evidence that they wish if they wish to
over
try to overcome a challenge that you're
interested
also you also in the circuit board there
is a procedure
that you could appeal it to the superior
court
but in the short term you would be able
to
have a full evidentiary hearing
involving
my testimony if that's of course a
personal wishes to take
the other section in it what it did
what i did was that this amendment
rewrites
well i thought it would capture the
intent of the paragraphs when we look at
our roman numeral three uh section b
two uh the original bill there was some
confusion on
how that that would operate in other
words
assumption whether what's the standard
along with the evidence there was some
confusion
what this does is
to do in cases where a person who's
charged with defense within the last
three years has
uh failed to appear at subsequent
coordinators
so an example would be you have a
suppression hearing just
press you know research you know
some of the governance from the area and
you have the police officer who's going
prosecutor a county attorney president
you can have a court president
everyone's going to be present
but if the person driving does not
appear
they normally they would be considered
being in default
well if a person fails to appear at
subsequent coordinators
three times um
in a three year period or two times on
the present case
and the case that they fail to appear on
is a felony
a class a misdemeanor or drunk driving
that
that under that case by the state can
show by preponderance
if a person has done that that person
would
then be detained now
and the reason why is that there's a
finding that
a person is detained on that section the
assumption is that the person is not
going to appear at the next quarter so
they would have had to commit that
or default three times in a three-year
period so
i don't believe that there's anything
egregious about that if a person
continuously does not show up for court
hearings to arrive at the conclusion
that if we release the person
it's unlikely that they will appear at
the next court hearing well
there is a track record for that but
again and that can be over or
you can overcome that that finding an
example i kind of came up with
hypothetical if there's a person in the
hospital but doesn't notify the court
well that person would be defaulting
because they didn't appear
but i highly doubt that that a judge or
the court would
hold that default uh you know in a
prejudicial management person especially
their their reason for not showing up
the what remains the same is the um
this doesn't compose or change anything
to do with
the idea of cash bail i understand that
there's been a lot of discussions on the
cash bail and how that can have a
discriminatory effect and have a
hardship on certain
people they they don't want people being
held on a thousand dollar bail simply
because a person cannot
pay a post that bit
so that that that if a person is
as assessely cash bail and they're
unable to pay it
you're going to have to demonstrate
without the demonstration by clearing
convincing evidence
that by requiring a cash flow
that that will assure that the person
will appear at the next year
so that's a higher burden
than hypothesis then under section
three c this has to move a person
is released on veil already
and they're charged with a felony class
a misdemeanor
or drunk driving and they get arrested
again
and they're before a felony classity
machine
with drunk driving and then so now i'm
that there will be a presumption fine
the state will have the excuse the
statewide the burden of proof
of probable cause that that person will
not abide by the conditions of their
release
when a person is released on bail is
i want to say universally always a
condition that you don't commit any
offenses
in this case this does not include class
b misdemeanors the reason for that is
if a person is charged with the class b
misdemeanor
that person would not be facing any gl
time so it wouldn't
make a lot of sense to hold a person
named custody for committing a classmate
misdemeanor
or to provoke their conditions of their
release or revoke their bail
because of that when the underlying
defensemen
actually improve jail again this can be
these all can be rebutted
under the hearing discussion in section
four
but again the reason why that standard
is probable cause
as opposed to the evidence because this
has to do with someone who's being
arrested and that's the standard for
wrestling so that you want the burdens
and the
findings to be consistent consistent
burden of proof throughout the process
since you're dealing with subsequent
arrests
so there was a case i know last year
where there was a person in new
hampshire in a two month time period was
arrested
five times for drunk driving in a
two-month time period
and the concern and people ask well what
happens happen well because you're not
convicted of any crime
if there are open charges the person is
really being charged with
five first offenses in the problem the
reason why that can happen
is because of the bail system by the
third
that would happen today by the third
drug driving
charge the court would then
they found probable cause would have the
opportunity to
detain the person and not earn these
things
so i i think getting to the point where
someone has five of these because
i might i don't i don't know the uh
you know details of the case beyond what
was reported in the media
but what i would say is that what this
is trying to do is avoid
situations like that we had a case where
you know if you go back to the other
paragraph involving the violent offenses
that's
rule number three that's romeo381
we had a situation where a person
committed they were arrested for
domestic violence
and within two hours that person was
released not
not they weren't brought before a judge
there's a bail commissioner
they were released and went back to that
person
and committed uh sexually sexually
assault that first person in front of
their
child so we're trying to avoid
situations where people commit violent
crimes
against people
and then they're released and they
commit similar offenses
and those egregious situations have
happened
several times really in a short
time period we had a situation where a
person
was broad the person is released
and the bra began within a 24-hour time
so it's my thought that we're trying to
avoid those
egregious situations it's the reason why
the bail commissioners
would not be making the determination of
clear and convincing evidence that's an
evidentiary that the
evidentiary standard it's a burden of
proof and its belief
my thought is that that should be
something that is decided by a judge
decided by the poor and we talk about
i'm talking about the crimes that are
violent really when it comes to domestic
violence that's what i'm i'm referring
to
murder rape child pornography these are
the crimes that i think we
we can make a suggestion of our pose a
threat to publicly
and i think in domestic violence it's
statistically showing that that's a
crime that elevates
and is often repeated and on the report
so when you have a situation where
elevation stop
and this is really taking consideration
by the nature of defense but also to
protect the victims of these crimes
to make sure that they're not going to
be repeatedly a victim
of the same curvature so i can answer
any
questions about this and hopefully
representative bradley you recognized
thank you chairman abbas
so just to be clear this amendment focus
so well in respect of roman numeral 3
a1 yes and that has to do the difference
between that section and the other two
sections i discussed
the other two sections discuss violently
dividing the conditions of your beliefs
so you those are not necessarily if you
don't show reporting
you're not committing a crime but
reviving the condition of the police
these i say determine violent crimes
some people make the argument that
statutory rape is not violent
maybe violence i'm looking at is that
still a serious crime against a person
so is it violent in nature perhaps not
but i would say the overwhelming
perpetra all these robbery i think
that's violent trafficking of a
i'm going to consider that to be a
serious offense against the person
you know this is violence i think that
it entails a threat that goes along with
kidnapping
aggravated felony sexual assault
second-degree assaults
under rsa 631
to domestic violence first degree
assault
homicide
stalking again stalking which is a
premeditated witness that involves
[Music]
against a crime against the person that
that's often a crime that can escalate
and against child pornography
child pornography is a crime where
simply having them because funding the
market for it the courts have
consistently found
and funding the market is in and of
itself supporting the industry
and you're supporting it that's
supporting a crime against a child
and these type of crimes i'm not
you can prostitute you convict the
person they can serve jail time
for someone who's worked on cases
involving crimes against
violent crimes against individuals i've
represented the defendants
and i've represented victims so i've had
a very
hands-on approach with dealing with this
and i i don't know
if it's if victims
truly ever recover from somebody the
person can serve jail time
they pay their debt but i think his own
the victim it's a tough situation
i'm not i'm not sure if they ever get
representative boardney thank you mr
chair
um you're the mission domestic violence
and protective orders
but aren't those two uh uh
crimes are aren't they already taken
care of
in present law
yes there the law addresses when you're
arrested for domestic violence or
violating
a restraining order if those are already
a crime and you're arrested for a crime
there are circumstances where you can be
held but one of the examples i
gave was a person who was arrested for
domestic violence and released
in within two hours and went back to the
alleged victims house
and then sexually assault that that
person in front of that person's child
so i would say is it addressed by the
law yes
but is it is it doing justice
i i think it's not in the interest of
the public
they have a system where people are
being released on these kinds of
domestic violence like crimes
where they're able to repeal and that's
why the state can
prove this by clear and convincing
evidence that they feel that that person
poses any type of threat
to whether it's the public or through
the u.s victim
themselves again just because you're
arrested for violating a restraining
order
or you're arrested with domestic
violence does not mean you're going to
be held the state has to demonstrate
why they feel that you are a threat to
the public now in order to do that we
can talk hypotheticals but there needs
to be
some some basis maybe the person has
several other violent convictions on
their record
maybe the evidence that they have been
presented during the hearing is
overwhelming whether there's text
messages or bruising or
or it's on video i mean we've seen that
where
things are captured on video so they
have situations like that if a person's
violating a restraining order
i understand there's already been
already have a victim of abuse
and now there's an order that's intended
to protect that person
and that person's not complete not
following the order
now just because someone violates the
order doesn't mean that they're
per se a danger to the public but i
would say that
they're certainly not following the
order they're unlikely following the
conditions of their obese if there is
an underlying criminal case so
i don't think the law sufficiently
addresses and provides enough protection
however president law does
make an exception for uh releasing on
uh without bond
for uh crimes of domestic violence
and validating a crim a protection order
that is in present law
the addition of other violent crimes
we have to consider that those are
accused they are not found guilty of
of having committed those crimes anybody
can be charged with a crime
that without net well evidence
so well i while i agree
that your amendment does narrow the
scope of
sb 92 i do not think it is ready
for becoming law
thank thank you in respect to that
anyone who's arrested who's not on bail
or
is going for a bail hearing hasn't been
detected so under that
logic you wouldn't have any jail system
whatsoever
so i think it's important to understand
that you're not you're right you're not
dealing with someone's being addicted
but the highest burden of proof is
beyond a reasonable doubt that's what
you need to get the conviction
the next step down is clear and
convincing evidence if the person is
simply charged
with it with one of these violent
offenses and
the district attorney or the county
attorney does not have
their uh their ducks on the road to
present
why that they believe that persons in
continued danger simply saying well they
were accused of this
i don't think that comes anywhere close
to using the burden of proof
you would have to provide some type of
phys if there is physical evidence or
it's photographs
often uh whether it's text messages
in writing and making threats there
would need to be more to meet that
burden
that's why they want to actually hold
the person and
if the state is able to do that
the defendant still has the option
to then have get a second hearing
under paragraph four where they can then
summons witnesses to actually appear
and testify and demonstrate again
why they're not a threat to policy but
the state can't meet that burden
you can be charged with any one of these
if they're unable to prove that
then the person should not be held i
mean that's that's a that's a pretty
high burden of food
for me really you're early on
but at this point when you're
investigating a crime it's either
something that just happened or the
person's been invited if the person's
been indicted
you're going to have a long list of
evidence to get gotten to the point
where you can make that argument
if if the crime just happened again
they're gonna have to be relying on
evidence why they're arresting that
person
again the surveillance video you're
gonna have something
to actually demonstrate why remain
attractive
so that's up to the state to meet that
bird
representative thank you thank you good
question
um do we have any statistics
on how many people are arrested and what
percentage of those
eventually go through the court system
and
[Music]
so from when people are charged with any
type of offense and whether they're
actually convicted
i don't have statistics
my i'm just speaking generally when you
have minor offenses meaning like class b
misdemeanors
or a classic involving when it's not a
crime against a person
if if a person there are different type
of plea deals that are
this guy oh these violent offenses
on okay so my understanding i don't have
the conviction rate
but my understanding that the belief is
there's about four to five thousand
these types of charges per year
now it's hard to just because sometimes
you can be charged with
second degree assault but also first of
all so some there is a little bit of
overlap
so one incident may involve well
the reason why they charge both they may
not get
first degree to solve this condition but
so
my understanding is that the consensus
is there will be about 4
000 of these types of arrests
involving an individual but that the
offense is higher than that for that
reason
so like child pornography you may have
several images or pieces of
videos or whatever child pornography
each one in of itself
would involve a potential charge
what i'm trying to get is
how many people who are charged with
these kinds of defenses
i worry about all of them
so i don't have the conviction rates and
then again
just because the person's not convicted
again if you plead down to something
else
the num the numbers can be deceiving but
i don't have the exact
same
thank you mr chair i just had a i had a
the specific changes
uh in this amendment uh were any of
those actually
vetted by the bail commission uh before
so did i are you asking if i even
vetted this bill for the bill the bail
commission
is the amendment that i vetted for them
that commission that's either the bill
or your amendment
i did not get the amendment before the
commission
uh and i will tell you that i don't
believe the underlying senator was
either
uh in respect to the the commission and
uh i believe
vice chairman welsh is a member of that
this was something that was before the
senate
there was a public hearing on it and
then there was a public hearing for our
committee
as well right
[Music]
up to 72 hours of schooling weekends and
holidays if they were charged with one
of these offenses
before they were brought to court i
dialed that down for 24 to 36 hours
and explained that why so i
reduced that time period where person
would be held
and you obviously you still have to take
into consideration the weekends and
politics
so that's the what this what this did
what this also did i because i added the
i uh
to if they're gonna in order for the
person to be held
it would be by clear convincing evidence
and my understanding
and of peace large new hampshire
if a person is going to be healthy and
it's involving a life sentence
and if you're going to deny that person
bail their
partner proof would be clear and
convincing evidence if you're going to
detain your personal life that's that's
the existing
law in the answer but i am doing not
some of these offenses as egregious
and as they are and violent as they are
towards a person
i'm putting that same standard ignorance
on a life sentence so it's a higher
standard
in my opinion with more narrow reply to
a person being held would say on
my domestic violence uh just a
misdemeanor address allowance charge
i'm putting that clearing convincing
evidence standard that would apply to
someone facing a life center so it's
i in my opinion it's actually upping or
increasing the burden
but no it was not invented for folks
mr chair i i appreciate the the time and
the effort
uh that it took to go through uh the
bill
uh and to make these changes and to uh
to make these recommendations and i
think that based on the problem that's
before us
um it's very possible that uh
the members of the dale commission could
have come up with exactly the same thing
um it's also possible that they could
have come up uh
with something very different uh and and
part of the problem
that i have with the process used to
create this bill
is we will never know that um because
we've short-circuited the role of the
bail commission uh in this process
um so my point isn't necessarily
that the changes uh the way that they're
framed in this bill
are are bad uh
um the i think the problem is is we had
a narrow set of stakeholders
that actually crafted this bill uh and
to my knowledge
we had two legislators uh following the
senate hearings
who sort of went over the bill again um
and
and crafted this amendment what we
really don't have
is full representation of all of the
different stakeholders
on the on the bail commission i think we
have a lot of representation
from the members of of of our police
departments
and i think they're important
stakeholders and they should have
a lot of representation but i think that
this is a state
where where ultimately legislators need
to write bills
based on the input especially a bill
like this
uh that's so complex and with so many
moving parts
we need to write bills advised by by all
of the stakeholders not just one narrow
set of stakeholders
so that's my issue uh with this bill and
that's my issue
with this amendment well i
can assure you of this that no
stakeholder wrote this on that board
i will i will assure you of that this
was something that was worked on
uh by myself with the input of another
representative who's not a member of the
committee
but who has a legal background of their
own
so this is not something that
necessarily was
this was not written by any organization
so
this the way this was written
i don't care who writes it if i put my
name on it
i would stand by it so it wasn't but
it's not not something that would
talk i would say it was written by an
organization or statement
i understand that thank you mr chair
representative
thank you mr chairman uh i i appreciate
the chairman's long explanation of this
amendment
and it confirms my assessment uh of the
amendment and that it contains many
substantial changes from the original
bill
as far as i can tell the language in
1549 it hasn't been reviewed in a public
hearing or work session
make no mistake this amendment will roll
back bail reform
in a large way in new hampshire and in
doing so it bypasses the established
process
they'll commission entirely this
language do not come out of the bail
commission
it does not reflect any of the
recommendations of the commission as far
as i can tell
and in fact the language contradicts our
critical finding from the commission's
latest report
which specifically states that failures
to appear have actually gone down
during the pandemic in part due to the
expansion of telephonic
check-ins additionally the language in
this amendment would impose significant
changes to a statute that was modified
just
this past summer since the enactment of
those reforms we've been in the midst of
a pandemic
resulting in numerous unprecedented
conditions and circumstances
to me it seems like we've not given the
most recent statutory change the chance
to soak in
we've not given the bail commission a
chance to review the effects of those
changes
and instead of waiting and listening to
the suggestions of the bail commission
this amendment seeks to place the card
before the horse
and push through some substantially
complex changes
how can we expect the bail commission to
do their work if we keep moving the
target
for this reason alone we should reject
this amendment but it's not the only
compelling reason
the second reason to oppose this
amendment is a financial one
as you know county delegations are
setting their budgets
currently i happen to be on the house of
corrections budget subcommittee in
hillsborough county
and they've reduced their budget
significantly due to a large reduction
in jail population
due to bail reform if this amendment
passes and bail reform is rolled back
this can cause a huge budget shortfall
of the county level
now i don't want to be responsible for
breaking the bank county level
and finally another compelling reason to
reject this amendment is legislative
liability
and what do i mean by that this
amendment attempts to convert an omnibus
bill into a single issue bill which i
certainly can respect however we must
not lose sight of the fact that amending
this bill
will result in a committee of conference
and i'm sure that most of you are aware
that the committee of conference can
generally
do whatever it wants to with the bill
and no doubt the members of the other
body will be pushing hard to reinstate
the pieces of the bill
which we're proposing to remove here
today
who's going to be selected to be put on
that committee of confidence
no one knows at that point the members
of this committee
will not have any real influence over
what happens to the bill
so i'm going to vote against this 11
hour amendment i would suggest that
the amendment were to fail that we
seriously consider retaining the bill so
the committee can use it as a possible
vehicle
for future changes recommended by the
best commissioner
thank you thank you
and just to clarify there's been less
court hearings all together
there was a good portion of the time
during the pandemic where the courts
weren't open at all unless it was an
emergency hearing
so yes the video hearings have
somewhat resulted in less defaults
but when the courts were closed in
general unless you were it was an
emergency hearing
you're going to have less defaults as
it's a matter of having lessons
processed in in regards to rolling back
bail reform
respectfully this doesn't roll back the
entire
failed reform operation this is only
applying to
violent crimes against crimes against
the person
once again felonies sexual assaults
child pornography crimes against
children rape and
this is not this is not rolling it back
on
people who are charged with something to
charge and trying to thrive in class
in regards to what happens at the
community conference i hope to be i
i can't if this were to pass and it's
not concurred by the senate i have no
i can't speak to the motives of what
would happen in there
um but i know that i if i i said i put
my name on an amendment
i put some time into it and uh
there was a lot of suggestions about
perhaps removing some of the violent
offenses from this list
to make it more to lower the impact on
the court and the lower the impact of
the county for the expenses
and the people i've talked to whether
it's
law enforcement or accounting levels
they are supportive
of this because of the public safety
aspect even though it could have any
potential
financial impact but i look at these
lists of offenses
and from a moral perspective i'm not i
wasn't willing to remove any of these
offenses
and if that if i am to be on the
committee of arms just like
yeah that's not my decision i wouldn't
compromise on removing any of these
offenses
just that's just my position i wouldn't
if i was going to just kind of
pass it through my goal is not to just
pass on the task i would stand by this i
the underlying bill i i thought the 72
hours was
a little uh too much so
and i still think it was representative
tester
[Music]
all right thank you mr chair
i have a question just for you could you
tell me who the representative was that
was speaking just before we can't tell
who who's in the room and i or i didn't
hear it
understand that that was representative
andrew
vanderbilt oh okay thank you very much
you're staying with everything you've
said
excuse me we're referring to my first
and last name just
it's just substantive for someone to
similar to me we have two greens today
as well
okay thank you
i agree uh with what he says especially
the financial part i was on the uh
on the uh the jail the way the jail
works now
the in hillsborough county they're down
by a hundred prisoners due to bail
reform
i think this is a made a massive uh
change to the bail commission
process the way it works now
in previous um meetings that we've had
i asked that what um the words
that it should be considered by the uh
by the court and the
bail commission what that meant and i
never did get a
satisfactory explanation but now as i
see in your amendment
it doesn't say the court and the bail
commissioner it says
the court and if applicable the bail
commissioner
and then later on it goes on to say that
in these cases as i understand it
it says that in in any of these cases
that the bail commissioners shall not be
assigned these cases um
so that leads me to believe that this is
an attempt to change the whole
all of the things that the bail
commission
recommended it's an attempt to change
the legislation that was passed seven
months ago
without any data and i appreciate all of
the anecdotal cases that you gave to us
and usually those anecdotal cases are
the most egregious
types of crimes and so that is kind of
i believe is intended to make us believe
that
that this bill should pass as as you
would like to see it amended
so
and i've talked i talked to a bail
commissioner an example of
things that could happen even
even if you change the hours to 36
people if i'm correct people that are
accused of these crimes now
go before bail commissioners and bail
commissioners make those decisions
i think you said something when you were
describing to us
all of the changes that were made you
didn't believe that the bail
commissioners could make a correct
judgment about the
various types of of necessary proof that
you have in this
and so you get to some anecdotal cases
that i heard from a bail commissioner
for instance
where there was a domestic violence case
with a with a man who had
alzheimer's and came before the bail
commissioner
and it looks to me that if this
amendment passes
that man would have gone would have
remained in custody
but he did not remain in custody he was
released to a family member
with conditions that he could not have
he had to stay away from the other
person and
then there was another example that he
gave was something about child
pornography
for someone that for whatever reason had
it on their computer maybe even
unbeknownst to them
that it was downloaded because they
visited a site
somewhere in in all of those people
would be retained in custody
because of that and they wouldn't see a
bail commissioner and if they don't see
a bail commissioner and they're arrested
at friday night at eight o'clock
they won't get to see a bail commission
they'll have to go to court and my
thinking would be
that the court would not happen until
the following monday and it was holiday
the following tuesday for those reasons
i am not going to support this amendment
represent newman used to clarify the
procedure if a person is
does appear before bail commissioner and
they are released or they have to they
post
bail not to the bail commission the
common practices
that the defendant would waive their
arrangements it wouldn't be
recording for an arraignment
and the reason why is that the
arraignment would be you would only do
that to challenge
because you disagree with the bail
commission with their determinations if
you
are uh i suppose
there's nothing uh no precedence for
someone challenging
a finding of a bail commission when they
paid and posted the
bail that the bail commission assessed
this is when i say that a bail
commissioner shouldn't be making
said finding if the finding is to detain
an individual
who's been charged with one of these uh
violent offenses
that that's a high burden of proof it's
clear and convincing evidence
and that is a high evidence for standard
that is
my my belief that it's more appropriate
that the court
made that determination because that's a
that's an evidentiary
determination that is often it should be
determined by a court and we can go
through several hypotheticals
but ultimately the state would have to
meet that burden
so whether a person's missed this
offense or not
there's no presumption that they'd be
held in the chart itself
uh in regards to child pornography and
that's
i'm to be honest i'm surprised that
that's one of the offenses listening
that's come up the most
so in my understanding
the internet crimes is children division
when they they're able to tell
uh we really follow the data in a way
that's uh
difficult to explain that they know how
long you've been on a website
they can tell if you've been whether you
meant to go to that website i guess you
can be like redirected to a
website and you're not sure you can they
can just tell
how long you've been there whether and
they also can tell whether you've
on a website and actually watched or
downloaded data websites from the
meaning you would have watched
some type of video so in that case
you're dealing with
if i were to make an arrest and i was
from i understand it's common
that no not warrants are often used in
these type of arrests
one about you know fear of the
destruction of evidence but to
the fear out of the officers
he was in florida some state but he was
certainly
knocked in the door and two federations
were shot right through the door
and they were serving a warrant on
childcare um
there's a lot of belief that a lot of
people charge this offense
tries to commit suicide by coughing
so in that type of case they're gonna
have
i would say they should they state if
they wish for the person to be
detained would need to present that
evidence in court and why they
they feel that person continue to pose a
direct public safety
so again that burdens on the state but
that's not
that's again that's not uh that
shouldn't involve someone who's
incidentally on a website for a short
period of time
i mean the states have to prove that
case at least at least in regards to
the burden to have the person detained
if that's what the state's asking for
maybe i don't understand the wording in
the amendment that deals with bail
commissioners
and it it says that
um these people shall not be brought
before a baal commissioner and shall be
held in custody
pending arraignment before the court
which shall without unreasonable delay
and within 24 hours of the time of your
arrest
excluding sundays and holidays etc so
does that not mean that anybody that is
charged with
these crimes
no matter what the circumstances are
will not be able to try
and refute the decision not to release
them
just explain that particular change to
me
so i understood during our conversation
there was some concern that bail
commissioners would be eliminated
altogether
they would bail commissions would still
exist they just
if you're charged with any of these
violent defenses
in that scenario you would not be
brought before bill commissioner
you would be pro you would be held to be
proper for the court so
depending on when you are arrested will
depend on when you were brought before
the court
so that's that's how that would work and
then there
so what would then happen you would have
your pale hearing
at the court which is that
during the time of your arraignment and
then what you can do is challenge that
if they make a finding by clearing
convincing evidence
you can then request the subsequent
hearing on character for
to summons witnesses and basically get
another
another chance to uh demonstrate why
you're not afraid privacy
is that instant good question well
i mean i'm looking at the exact words
and it says they shall
be held in custody and to me
my fear is that anyone
that is arrested and charged with one of
these crimes
shall be held in custody they won't see
a bail commissioner
who could make a decision to have them
released in the current system
and they will remain in custody and if
it happens
depending on the timing they could be
held up
held in custody for much longer than 36
hours so unless we're going to have
court hearings i i don't know how they
would
get released maybe you can explain it to
me so
if if you get arrested for one of these
appointments
you you can be held for up to 24 hours
but no more than 36 hours it has to
exclude the weekends and holidays if you
have to be brought before
the court that when you're brought
before the court that would be
the arraignment if the state does not
ask me to be
detained which again i would
i'm not sure the will on every single
one that's up to the state to ask
if that is the case and the state meets
the burden of proof
then you'll be detained if you don't it
insists to attend the paragraph
if the court does not find by convincing
evidence that a person must be detained
of course i'll order the person at least
so is so is everybody detained or not
excuse me can i have a follow-up yes
yeah not everybody that is my follow-up
so you are arrested who have been placed
under arrest
when i use their term detained that
would be impact when you
your bail is when you have your bail
hearing for the court
it's you're going to remain in custody
until you have you're probably
24 to 36 hours and you
you are then you could be detained if
was that newman yes thank you for the
follow-up especially since it's probably
the so you said when brought before the
court
if they're arrested on a friday night
when are they going to be
brought before the court because now
that the bail commissioner is not
involved
there is not a person who can make a
determination whether he can be released
or the person can be released meaning
all of them
and they it's subject to a burden of
proof
that happens before a court but i think
our understanding is that the
person in that circumstance would not
get to a court
until the following monday or tuesday i
i'm just confused on how this thing is
going to work
all of a person's arrest
felonious sexual assault
robbery possession manufacturing
distribution of child
sexual abuse images you're arrested on a
friday night
and you would you would have to be
brought before the court within 24 hours
of them
being open now it's schools weekends and
holidays and that's the bypark
court not being open and that's
currently um
not every not every situation the
person's necessarily thoughtful
it's not always done that so
that's something that's sometimes at the
auction so
they're going to be held for that time
period waiting wait if they're ready
that's how this will work if if they
don't bring the person within the 24
hours and the weekend
and holiday exclusion doesn't apply with
the 36 hour which doesn't apply
they're not being they're holding that
person
i would say illegal they need to be
brought within a reasonable time
even 24 hours the person should they
should not be up against the clock
they should be processed and brought to
the court as soon as possible within a
reasonable time
and i believe it's not done very much
and just to clarify even if you're
brought within a 24-hour time period
24 hours to the court it doesn't
necessarily mean that that was not a
reasonable time period
just sitting i would find that to be
thank you for that clarification but
right now they see bail commissioners
and for these laws they won't see those
bail commissioners now
representative klein knight thank you
chair
um i i think it's inappropriate for us
to kind of skip the line and
not uh take the advice of a of a whole
commission that just
passed a law that we haven't even
been able to see the effects of because
the courts have been
shut down because of kovid so we haven't
even been able
to see how this new law
that all the stakeholders met to
effectively come up with in a bipartisan
and collaborative
way i just don't think
the democratic the democratic process is
is is getting a fair shake if we're
bypassing
a whole group of people from all over
that have the most important voices
to to an experience
to raise in this issue and
we're basically you know ignoring their
advice
by not even seeing how what they came up
with first is going to affect our state
and i don't think anybody is going to
argue that these are really heinous
crimes and we take them very seriously
but due process and you know fair
democratic
instances for people getting their time
to you know prove to everyone that they
are innocent and heaven forbid
like you know we round people up that
are innocent and then they
they aren't treated fairly and we have
to wait days
um i just i think we open this state up
to litigation
um by uh by not
fairly incarcerating people
uh you know we just got sued because we
were doing that in the er
you know and we even have inmates right
now waiting for
psychiatric care we can't even house the
public
effectively for that kind of situation i
don't
see us throwing more resources at our
um inmate population so this is
this is a really big issue that i don't
think we've had enough time
to get everybody's opinions on
that will be affected by this if it were
to pass and i
i think it would be really irresponsible
of us to pass this
without hearing all those voices from
the people that have the most experience
in our state
on this issue um thank you
thank you representative i will just
point out there was
public hearings from the senate you know
public hearing police committee so any
stakeholder any member of any commission
anyone
[Music]
multiple opportunities to offer their
input
on this on senate bill 92
there was plenty of opportunity to do
that so no one's been excluded from any
process
i think looking at what we have before
us here
where this is not something that is
being done
to go around anyone's
recommendation there are commissions
that exist
that put together recommendations uh
those recommendations
are up for this committee to evaluate
and
it's up to other the legislator
is the one that actually is the body
that actually decides which part of his
recommendations
sure should not be involved so i don't
think that we are necessarily bound by
another whether it's a interest group or
a commission's recommendation
it's certainly helpful but no one's been
excluded from the process
any any insight on this i'm looking at
it as
i would i would ask a question you can
answer
which part of section 381 do you feel
that is inappropriately included
what part of that process is
inappropriate because i'm under the
existing law
if you're charged with homicide for
instance any offense with a life
sentence
the standard is clear and convincing
evidence whether you're going to be
detained or not
so that's already a practice being
followed in the state
and we are adding well other
less seriousness and homicide we're
adding other offenses to that
standard to that category where it could
be detained
by meaning that if the state needs that
high burden of proof
so i guess the question is do we want a
i think we need to get more of the
stakeholders in the room and see what
their thoughts are not just the chief of
police
and i i think that we need to heal hear
from the bail commissioners
um you know i i just don't think this is
giving a fair shake to all parties
involved
and what really troubles me is an
overnight stay
or a whole holiday stay just because we
don't have
the judges or or the time to book people
properly
and that right there leads us open
for um involuntary incarceration
that you know that we just got sued for
like i'm saying it i just think that
there this
we didn't have enough time to study the
potential effects
of how this is going to be after it's
implemented how
it's going to affect everyone so that
that and this is the community put in
consideration
last week representative knights
corrected the case
came out of the supreme court in new
hampshire if you were involuntarily
detained you had a right to rehearing of
the 72 hours well the issue was that
there wasn't
enough room in the facility for people
who were
being involuntarily detained and
the question was when does the clock the
72 hour clock begin
and some people took the position that
it doesn't begin until you have your
placement so people were in who were
sitting in the emergency room let's say
for
two weeks waiting for availability they
were being held during that time
in the new hampshire supreme court ruled
that the unconstitutional
i agree with that decision and i don't
think that
just because there's not enough
resources that a person should
be held representative
a person is being held over a weekend or
holiday because the court itself is not
open
and that's currently a problem that i
don't know
many courts that are old they don't open
on the weekend
so that's not that's not something that
we're
we're changing so that's that
i will say in regards to resource issues
when we
when hb 2 passed in the house we did
create
two additional positions for circuit
court judges
my understanding the senate is of course
the
budget hasn't passed but they've created
two more additionally so there'll be
four additional circuit court judges
to address this
and so i think that the resource
argument issue has been at least
somewhat addressed by what is uh what is
being done but that we have no control
over
what the two additional ones pass on
that's that's not that's for finance
committee to i support the adding of
those judges but i can't
control whether they remain or they get
posted taken out
sorry can i just add a comment
i i don't think this is this
may be a bad idea i i'd like to
retain it or i'd like to to have more
time on it is what i'm saying
so we can really study all the details
of how it's going to affect the whole
process the bail commissioners the
police
the person incarcerated you know i just
don't think
there's so many moving parts to this
that i just don't think we have spent
enough
time on it for to to make it the best it
representative you're recognized thank
you mr chairman
i respect the bail commission
very much but they were appointed by the
government
we are the legislators that are sent up
here
to respect the people and protect them
so many things have gone on in the past
seven months that we are laughed at
because we made a building
and i want you to know that the film has
been in place before for many years
and it seemed to work all right none of
us want to put
anybody in jail because they did
a minor thing and it doesn't happen that
way
my apologies to my fellow democrats
but i will vote for this amendment
representative rose you're recognized
[Music]
there's a lot to say here and the first
thing i would like to say is
with respect to what representative
pandalatas just said
is one of the things i have written on
my notes we aren't talking about keeping
somebody
in jail that ran a stop sign
we're not talking about keeping somebody
in jail they was arrested for smoking
marijuana
we were talking about keeping somebody
in jail
that has done horrendous horrendous
or is accused of doing a horrendous
thing
and it's very easy to stand back and say
well the person needs to be heard
what about the victim why are we we are
protecting the wrong people here
and when it's your family member or it's
your child
that is the victim that is this
child pornography it's their image
that's on the computer
you're going to think differently about
that person being released
they did that and it's very easy to
stand there and say
you're protecting these people but
you're not you're not protecting these
people
you're you're riding this justice horse
and you're getting nowhere what if it's
your child
that was held down that was raped to
death
oh we'll let the guy out he it's been
three days we need to protect him no we
don't
you need to think of the victims
it's it's not as simple we're not
talking about a mistake
right we're not talking about calling a
tomato
a vegetable going into fruit we're
this isn't this is insanity we are not
we're not talking about small things
here
and i think everybody that's sitting
here protecting the people because they
may have to sit in jail for three days
well lucky then it's only three days
because the victim
is being affected for the rest of their
life
and so is their family these are huge
consequences the people when they're
convicting these crimes
they're not thinking about because
you're only thinking about themselves
they deserve to be in jail
that's all i have to say thank you
just clarify it too for the person
the person's help they're detained
again the state that's what their
request
has to present enough evidence to
demonstrate by
clearing against the evidence that
person is a threat to
the public or themselves so again this
the court would be needing to make a
determination
this individual who's been charged with
a violent offense against someone
is continues to be a threat to public
safety
and that's that's the point i'm trying
to get across you need to
it's not just to be committed to crime
itself it's
it's whether you actually remain a
threat to public safety
is the issue of whether you'll be
pleased so
whether that's done by a judge or a bail
commissioner i i think having a judge
evaluate
that burden and prove by having a higher
standard
is allowed really lets you identify the
individuals who
actually have a more accurate findings
it's a higher burden done by a judge
i think i'm not saying that i don't know
what they're doing but i
would put the credibility of a judge
thank you mr chairman i'll start by uh
thanking you for the good faith effort i
think you put into addressing concerns
that were in the initial bill
um i'll also echo comments by
made by several members that you know we
don't really have all the information
the premise behind the initial bill that
we're
considering the amendment on was that
the effort from a few years ago
had flaws and so now we have
an effort to quote unquote fix it that
hasn't been thoroughly vetted
so i'm inclined to to support this
effort
i would also be inclined to support it
in a year when we have more time to look
at the effects
so that's all i'll say but um
so i remain torn on this but i would i
think we can
get a bill we all can support if we hold
on to this
for a few months work on it in the fall
bring it back early next year and get it
and representative collins let me ask
and i i respect the dialogue that we're
having today
i understand i think we're all doing
we're all boys and concerns i appreciate
that
when it comes to making changes or
potential changes to what
the amendment that's being presented i
what will we change about i i look at it
as
we have a limited scope of the offenses
where this would apply to
uh that's the crux of what this is
and is it the preference that that's
that is decided by a bail commissioner's
postal judge
i i guess my question is if there's
suggestions to be made i'm more than
willing to listen
and i took i've consulted a lot of
different
uh members and a lot of different people
when putting this together
and took into consideration a lot of
different that's if you notice there's a
couple amendments floating around
and every time when i say that i
respected a lot of different opinions on
this is one
opinion satisfied in its entirety no
but there was some other balance we have
to kind of
juggle some of the things together to
make it address
all uh a lot a lot of concerns i guess
i'm asking you guys what concerns do you
have that you would prefer change do you
want to limit eliminate some of these
offenses would you rather bail
commissioners
uh decide bail when someone's charged
with aggravated felon
sexual assault as opposed to judge
so i go back to the fact that i am not
an expert on these things
and i listen uh
to people who know more than i do and
consider the arguments they make
and there seem to be compelling
arguments on
truly compelling arguments on both sides
so
i think your amendment goes a long way
to addressing the concerns i had
at the same time um
i look back at some other bills we've
retained
in my mind were great didn't need more
work but i think that retaining them
ended up being the correct decision
because i think it's going to get us to
a final product that we can all
or hopefully a large majority of our
committee can support
and i see this as part of the same that
same
in that same vein if there are problems
with bail
we absolutely should fix it i think
we're on the right track
rather than identifying individual
issues i think it's more about getting
members to be more comfortable with the
potential effects
of this amendment that we haven't had
testimony on
uh at all so that's that's what i would
where my argument comes from for
retaining
nothing suggesting there's a problem
with this more about to slow down
this process and do it right so that we
don't have more bail reform
coming back before this body in this
uh but when we retained some of the
bills those are house bills and we had
we had a specific deadline to meet and
we had 59 bills i i think i
i think our committee had the most so
some of those bills we were not you know
i wasn't ashamed to admit
we were only going to meet on limited
basis as well based on what was
available
more
for this bill this has been assigned to
our committee for over a month
and i said last meeting before
the rules only allow us to put forward
one of them
you can't have multiple amendments to a
bill and if there's any
amendment or any change anyone wants to
work with anyone else putting forward an
amendment
so they can you know take it to consider
and put all things together
um i respectfully i haven't had many
people
especially your caucus come to me and
asking me to make any specific changes
to
the prior amendment that was circulated
around or
or the one that was i think this is now
the third version of my draft it's kind
of
floating so i'm just i haven't been
no suggestions and they've got me in a
month
so i'm still all ears but a lot of
people want to say that we want to study
more but we've had the bill for
quite some time so i'm just wondering if
we retain it
i'm just curious on the time frame that
if we're actually going to
be looking into this so i'm not i
haven't
haven't been presented any ideas so
chairman can i
respond and then i'll i'll mute myself
and we'll talk again so i
my concern is again as a layperson
making changes on this broad scale that
affect
uh you know a vast number of people who
are arrested
will be detained will have costs
involved uh stresses on the court system
these are legitimate things that we just
don't have information on
and you know there are bad faith efforts
in this house to delay and delay and
hopefully kill
my suggestion is not one of those
efforts
let's get something that we can all
support or the majority of us can
support and address the concerns
so that we're not having um
these we just haven't we don't have all
the information so
that's the point that i'm raising not
that it's a bad amendment doesn't seem
to be
but there's just things that a lot of us
have raised that we don't have answers
and can't get answers at this moment
thank you i'm calling from sam green
thank you uh i represented dennis green
thank you uh my thing is that
i think you put a lot of work into it
and we've had time to work on this
and no one has come forth other than the
time that you put into it
and i think if we pass it
then if there's some discrepancy that
somebody could put in a bill next fall
and change maybe one or two parts of it
but i think it's time to
uh pass it and put away some of these
criminals
a long time ago i never did that's right
yeah
that involved so i just let you run with
it um first of all
[Music]
i just want to address something that i
just heard that no one's ever said
anything
to or or had conversations with you and
i've had conversations with you
in regards to this particular bill and
the reason why i had the conversation
because
um bradley raymond
sent us that commission on pre-trial
detention pre-trial scheduling
and the services and i took the
opportunity to read through it i hope
that the rest of my colleagues read
through it
because that was an important um
commission
and i just want to say let me give you
an idea who was on that commission
even though two people wrote the
amendment that you had
so and i also want to speak to another
colleague who talked about the passion
of the victim i don't think anybody in
this room was more passionate
about a victim than myself but i am
about due process of law
so uh we had two senators as a matter of
fact that
shared that commission all right both
sides of the aisle
we had um representative rod
that's no longer with us but she was
upon that commission
representative woodbury representative
welch
uh the honorable david king new
hampshire circuit court
the honorable tina nader new hampshire
superior court
attorney thomas burlappi associate of
county attorneys
attorney sean locke officer the attorney
general
superintendent stephen church rockingham
county corrections
attorney randy hawks new hampshire
public defender
those are people that were on that
committee and believe me
they have a lot more uh education than
most of us in this room today
and take that a little further chief of
police
uh department of corrections everyone
had the
opportunity to come and testify before
this committee
and the community the people our
constituents
came and spoke before this committee
so we had so as far as i'm concerned it
was
a huge number of people that
vetted this for roughly what three years
david i think about three years so when
you tell me that you can walk in and fix
this and uh
what 60 days whatever days you said i
have a problem with that
and i should have everyone in this room
should have a problem with that
because these are the people that wrote
it and if you think that there's a flaw
to it
then do the right thing and then be
vector i'm not talking about necessarily
our committee
yes maybe those from alchemy but it
needs truly needs to go back or it needs
to be vetted whether we retained it
i have no problem retaining the bill but
the proper people come before us
remember
the only people that testified was the
chief of police department
one of the questions that i asked that
day if
the bail bondsmen disagree or you have a
disagreement what is your request
and he said contact the judge so there
is an avenue
today for them that disagree the other
piece of that that came up was what
percentage
all right and talking and looking at
some of the data here
you're probably talking about two
percent maybe
maybe and maybe not even that so i'm
still gonna say i have a problem with
the
number one i definitely have a problem
with the amendment but i haven't had a
problem with the entire bill
from day one that we had the bill and we
have had the conversation
i actually talked to another colleague
here um do you think that the commission
might be meeting anytime
soon you know are you guys the phone or
whatever which i couldn't really get an
answer about that i think it was because
of covet
they weren't meeting anymore but i think
there's a possibility that we can
give this to a group of people that
really can vet this
issue that was brought before us by the
chief police
and mind you the day that we had that
hearing
i got home played my voicemail a
commissioner
unfortunately he couldn't be there he
said but we didn't know
you even had that bill so i struggle
with
the fact that nobody else testified
outside of the chief of police
there's a problem because the
stakeholders were many
and i would like to see the stakeholders
there again
i would like to hear from uh
rape and assault i would like to hear
from all the different groups
that came out to testify and to work on
this to make this
a a unique thing for a pre-trial
so with that said i can't support the
amendment
and i definitely did not support the uh
the bill so representative i
i don't remember i don't have the list
of every member who testified
i'm not excuse me members i remember the
public
i do know it was beyond it was more than
just
you know someone from the chief of
police associations and
that testimony was in support of the
underlying bill which i think that
the amendment um dials that
when i see thousands of back i mean this
is less
restrictive than the underlying senate
bill that came
so what the chief of police association
of the government
testified for the committee this is not
this is not exactly um this is again 72
hours
so and now i'm not going to speak for
members of the public that i consulted
with because i don't want to
put words in them but i did speak with
several more than one judge about this
topic
that was done i did speak with uh
practice interns in the state of new
hampshire among us
and there was input in that regard i
spoke with uh
members of the court system so
i those police officers yes
i there was a lot of consultations in
mind
that with this and i've been open about
discussing this with anyone who wants to
discuss
the policies of how to how this should
be drafted
um and i would say the co-sponsor has a
legal background
as well of the amendment and is also a
retired judge
so when i say that i work with
i think this is a senator i did i
discussed this bill with
members of the senate that's correct i
did so
i'm not saying that i have this
supermind that's greater than the
commission
put together but there was a lot of
consultation done
and arriving at what is being presented
for the king today
even the amendment that was that was
being floated around last i believe last
week the week before
again since that was out
the reason why there's some changes made
to take into consideration
some of the thoughts are right
some thoughts and just because someone
makes a recommendation doesn't mean
supportive of the entire amendment
but it did kind of when i said it's a
balance in but that was done
and again from a due process perspective
a person is being
arrested if the state can demonstrate
the burden of proof by clearing
convincing evidence
that they remain a threat to public
safety
then that they're allowed that's that is
satisfying due process that's
consistent with the new hampshire spring
course prior decisions
they can make a determination and that's
involved in life sentences but this is
that's the burden of proof you can have
a lower burden of proof if it doesn't
involve
life sentence but i am putting i believe
the higher burden of proof is what's
appropriate to have and
that's what this would yeah
so i i don't believe anyone was excluded
from the process again i understand it
so recognized okay so i'm going to say
that yesterday
they were excluded because you said that
you had the conversations with
so many people okay this should have
been
something that there was committee or
detained so that
everyone could hear what these people
were saying
i don't believe that because you had a
conversation with um
a judge uh a lawyer and whatever else
you named
that that's enough giving what it took
two and a half years for people to do
and you're saying that you were able to
get this
done um and then reassess within a
what 60 day period however how long he
had to build
but i will say again that there's too
many
if he's about this this situation
in terms of the
in terms of the documentation that was
provided to us
that the committee did so i would like
to see this go
um be retained and that we have
the judge or the police officer or
whoever
the citizen anyone that cares about
the system in terms of due process as
well and as well as our victims
come before us and uh give us that
feedback
because otherwise i feel as though the
two and a half years that folks spent
truly digging digging into this i look
at
notes like from friday october 18th on
pretty much every month through october
20th of 2020 what they did to um
to come up with this document and to
come up with the recommendations
and if there's if there's a issue
whether it's training or whatever it is
that
the chief we seem to have with the
veiled bondsmen
i think that's an issue that should be
resolved i don't think that should be
resolved through law i think that should
be
resolved in training if i remember
correctly we had a bill
about this additional training and uh
and any changes in the law
and how quickly this stuff funnels down
to the mailbox we went through all this
what a couple months ago so again i'm
gonna
um reach out to my colleagues and say
that um
i would appreciate if we get together
and retain this and i think there'll be
several people
because if there's a two percent and
you're trying to change the law for two
percent of the state of new hampshire i
have a problem with that too
well let me just clarify when i say
people are
no one's been deprived of offering an
import
again there's been a public hearing
schedule not just
for this group this is a senator so
there were multiple public hearings
available for any member of the public
to express themselves
whether they were a member of the bail
commission or not
now i don't know the senators who sit on
that
[Music]
but let's just send it to me for her
my point is that when you have multiple
public hearings it's my opinion
i don't feel that anyone's being
excluded in the process
they're free to come testify before the
committee and offer
their their opinion on what's being
brought forward then
for the two percent again that not every
single person is going to be
the changer when you have people being
arrested and
for domestic violence and they're
literally being released within the
knowledge
about paying that offense and they can't
that same exact defense or even worse
that's under the current bail system
that has been put into place
that is what we have happened now does
it happen does it happen all the time no
but this put if you can make a
demonstration to the poor
that that type of defense this person is
likely to commit another violent crime
against someone else that's when they
would lead the team it's not a
per se you are being held simply for
your child being charged
so i i don't feel that there's a due
process
right i believe a person is innocent
until he's proven guilty
that's overall that's the way i should
work
uh some i'm gonna vote for those
by the way but i don't agree with that
[Music]
so representative thank you mr
chairman i hope that you will not retain
this bill
it's been long enough that this bail
commission or any of these other people
have been taught
we have to think of the people out there
that can get hurt
if we have flaws in this amendment we
can correct it
representative oh excuse me uh
representative hawker hasn't spoken so
let me know i'll just uh
well that's not an appropriate motion
um i will accept that as a
recommendation
i will say i know it's been going on for
a little while i'm sorry that it's uh
but i don't i don't want to end cut off
the discussion people have the hand
story so
i think after we have represented
boarding representative newman
with the hands raised and uh
representative andrew bolden so
i would like to recognize them to speak
again to respond to any uh
comments and then i i think after that
that despite her avid strong
disagreement
representative you recognized
thank you mr chairman well after reading
the
present law and uh your proposed
amendment
i'd like you to look at
page 1 uh line 17.
it looks like according to what i'm the
way i'm reading it because
one of the choices is detained is that
even now we don't need anything
we can retain anyone uh
then we'll go down to uh uh
section three are you on the amendment
that we represent the amendment yes it's
it's the same as as it is in
rsa
the choices are to uh
be released on personal resonance
released on condition of combinational
conditions retained
are temporary retained i would propose
that since we are
looking at this section of law
that c should probably be removed
then we go down to paragraph three which
is in the rsa
not in your not in your amendment
um i'll read it a paragraph section
three
paragraph a what
can you repeat the rsa or yes this is
back to the rsa
uh paragraph a safety of the public are
are the defendant if a person is charged
with any criminal offense our offense
listed in
uh domestic violence are are
vali in a predictive order or etc so
by looking at the words any criminal
offense
what has happened is with you listing
a laundry list of offenses you have
narrowed the sculptable law
uh as well as uh
making us reveal revisit
this section of law uh anytime we
need to to add on a different
another offense so
we can we can retain it and try and fix
up
all of uh rsa
598 colon 2 or we can just let it go as
the idea was to limit the scope of when
it would apply to what type of offenses
and
i don't again i don't if it's not
included in that list it will fall
outside
so i'm not aware of any violent crimes
against a person that could be added to
that list if there is one i would
certainly support adam that's
representative uh andrew bolden thank
you mr chairman
um i think it's more important that we
get this right and get it done
today i've heard a couple of members on
this committee say
well maybe the language isn't quite
right but we can fix it later we'll fix
it next year
in fact we have a few amendments which
have been floated around as the chairman
stated via email
um it's clear that there's a lot of
discussion on this bill
we've got a bail commission that we
should be looking for guidance from
let's give ourselves some time to do
this the right way
get language that we can not just agree
on but we can feel good about it
thank you mr chair i'll be brief i i
also believe that someone who's charged
with a crime they're innocent until
proven guilty
and i know there are egregious places
where people got out and did bad things
and
and those are terrible and should be
stopped and i think they're entitled to
due process
and under the current system of bail
under the current law they have their
due process
served by i don't know what bail
commissioners are members of the court
but they are certainly
part of the government and those people
make decisions about whether they should
be released or not considering their
dangerousness
and threat to public safety and
and probably um uh
flight and so i think that by removing
the bail commissioners and
it was not explicit in the original bill
that that was going to be
the effect of the bill but it is
explicit in
this amendment that bail commissioners
will
not hear anybody who is
charged with these particular offenses
and without that they're denied due
process in it
but the process they do get may fall
in line with what the court decisions
are on
when only a court is involved so my big
problem is the removal
of the bail commission is completely
from these crimes
and for that reason i will not vote for
well i'm waiting for a member to return
to the room representing
i can inquire a question so
do you believe that a per a person's
due process is being violated if they
are not
afforded an opportunity to be presented
you're muted if that's the question for
me i think that's how
they get that due process today
so if there's any circumstance where a
person is not
before bail commissioner like if they
commit capital murder
or homicide and that's an area where
they're not normally brought before bill
commissioner anyway
i mean do you believe that that's a due
process violation
i don't know what actually i don't know
what the process
is for who makes the decision when the
police come
to charge somebody with a crime and the
bail commissioner makes a judgment based
on that
i don't know who the arbiter is at that
point and i think that perhaps it's the
bail commissioner
i think that in those cases the bail
commissioner
in in the capital murder case would
probably
detain the person because of the
conditions of the that particular case
and my concern is is that in those cases
people like that should be retained
but my fear is that if you completely
eliminate the bail commissioners
everyone who is charged for any of these
offenses
especially the ones like um
domestic violence that's that's a a big
one
but you can do very small amounts of
inappropriate or unwarrant i forget
exactly the language
unwarranted touching and it ends up that
people
end up that all of those people would be
retained
and i think that people underestimate
for the normal person who got
into the criminal justice system under
those kinds of circumstances
for them to spend the weekend in jail
or or be there for a period of 72 hours
especially if they are not very wealthy
and
and can't need to have their job and
everything there's a lot of things that
can happen to those people
that shouldn't have to them if they get
what i think now is proper
due process
reminder
you want to have our videos on time to
matter
[Music]
you remember disney at home is that
um
seeing no further hands raised the
matter will now be put to question
amendment 2021-1549-h
please say yay if you are opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the world
vice chairman welch aye
representative bob green aye
representative hopper yes representative
dennis green
yes representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true
yes representative pratt
representative marston yes
the clerk votes yes representative
harriet gathright
no representative pantalakis yes
representative massimila no
representative bordenay no
representative newman no
representative andrew bolden no
representative conley
no representative klein knight
no representative bradley
yes
mr chair the votes the vote is 13 yay
8 may a vote of 13 years
eight days the motion of well the most
to adopt
the amendment has passed
considering the lengthy discussion we
just had
on whether to adopt the amendment uh
i don't i believe it would be
appropriate just to leave the question
a motion ought to pass as amended yes
chairman i would like to make mercy
ought to pass for senate bill 92.
thank you when is that seconded
a second the motion about the pastor's
amendment has been seconded by
representative
greene
see see no further hands raise
the matter matter when lb put the
question
which in support of the most about the
past has amended please say yay
representative bob green no
representative hopper yes representative
dennis green
yes representative wallace
yes representative testerman
yes representative true no
representative pratt yes
yes the clerk votes yes
yes representative massimo
no representative bordenay
no representative newman
no representative bowden i'm sorry
andrew borden
absolutely not representative connolly
no representative prime knight
no representative bradley
no chairman
i'm the chair of jess you missed music
did you call me
i was uh my apologies that was
that was a mistake i'm sorry
representative muse
uh no chairman the chair votes yes
mr chair the vote is
11 a nine yay
i'm sorry twelve i my apologies okay
news is up on the on further on the
on the note the vote is 12 may
nine
[Music]
so not to pass the event no
no
[Music]
representative get right i i do have it
but he was he's further on the list you
exacting
296 was uh faster than the senate that
was meant
so sp
hb296
so
[Music]
used crayons that i changed the name of
the crane
red is red blue is blue green is green
did you bring in more of those
delicious looking sandwiches man those
i didn't bring food today because i
is
[Music]
um
oh it is because i'm on the same
committee they are on and we just we
296 right okay that's that's that's one
with a set of change
i think you're just going to discuss
maybe they're changed
but it was was it a house club 296 i
don't remember
yes because the senate changed you sent
it to them all right
and so concur not concur or go to
committee
can we get a copy of that they have no
official notes
like that underlying fiscal bill
oh
[Music]
mostly it's mostly administrative work
but it's mostly administrative work not
only
yeah so there was a new piece of
personnel
if you put somebody in the county jail
yes the jail populations have gone down
and in some cases they don't have enough
yes the reason why it's in the
determinant of the website when you have
a new standard
determine
it says indeterminable because they
can't
how many if you had four thousand of
these type of charges you have to
determine how those four thousand how
many would be
held there's no way to determine that
because there's no sample
or you'll pull to pull it so
if they even if they gave you a number
it would be a guess or an estimation
because
any time any case you have to be very
back specifically
why that person was held or not so
then when it comes to administrative
tasks of course from during the
administering process that's not only
put into a distance so that wouldn't be
there now
hiring the additional judges and that's
just
yeah having that we have to the cast in
our
until it's passed i mean
so
reconvene the criminal justice public
safety committee all right accept my
apologies for delay
see a few hands raised does that the
members have questions they wish to ask
for some pancreas
this is damn i would like to know if we
i could make a motion
92 senate bill 92
are you are you asking if there's going
to be a motion
if i couldn't make a motion or if
there's
and representative before we make
yes
so you remember uh one of the statements
i made earlier
concerning your amendment page 1
yes i went back
to the 2018-2019
annual dated criminal law and
that is not in there i also
checked the changes for 2019
and found out that section of law had
not been amended
so i think that that detained
is a error that has crept in
from paragraph two
it says accept as provided in paragraph
three
or four these are the options so
that person is not going to generally
just be detained simply because they
were arrested
for no reason at all it's in the current
law
it isn't that i mean
i thought it was the current law it's in
the
[Music]
it is in that book it isn't in the
previous book
so and we did not make any changes
because i just looked at all the changes
for 2019 and 2018
there was no change to that section of
597.
okay now i understand what you're saying
okay
uh representative anthologist you wish
[Music]
mute
i was wondering if i could make a motion
all right student representative you
faded out you mind repeating that
i wanted to know if i could make a
motion
on senate bill 92
you were recognized to make a motion on
senate bill 92
i make a motion that we reconsidered
is that seconded by anyone
i'll second all hello representative
uh i appreciate you stepping up the
second announcement
because you're a substitute you're not
allowed to i'm not doing that all right
would any member
we discussed it long enough it's been
hard to add to the discussion
that the motion to reconsider has been
seconded by representative rose
of representative pandolas who wish to
speak to your motion to reconcile
i would like to make another motion
after this
without a motion to reconsider that's
what i'd like to do
my understanding is that the bill can be
retained without
whether the amendment a subcommittee
would be appointed in uh as everyone
said that they're so interested in
working
diligently to master the craft of this
bill
that i'm sure that the subcommittee
would
make some changes whether it would be
amended underlying bill but just
remember
am i able to recommend your amendment
to retain it in in well
in the sub if it's retained the
subcommittee will be appointed
representatives i see you take an
interest in
such a minute uh yes that amendment
would still exist and we could change
one word in it it would have to be a new
amendment but
it wouldn't it would still be something
so let me ask is that if your
intention is to retain the bill
would you wish to withdraw your your
motion for reconsideration
and then be recognized for an emotion to
retain yes
and representative rose would you wish
rob the second as well yes
representative did you have a question
that you'd like to ask before
representing
motion represent newman here so
recognize
great questions i just i just have a i
just want to
comment green query what what is the
current status
of the bill what was the current status
of the bill before the motion was made
did did we vote on that
it failed it was the most
was the most about the past and to offer
an amendment
but then the author passed as amended
failed so now our option is
we could retain it or maybe speed the
legislation
clarification
so representative panduragus do you wish
to be recognized
for a motion to retain yes i would
i make a motion retain house bill 92
so it can be said
and is there someone that remember which
is second the most became represent
popper
you senator pandemics you wish to speak
to the motion
well i just think that there needs to be
um
changes in the law now and i think if we
committed together we could work on it
it's on the official note it says they
have something there but
[Music]
yeah so before we go to the
voting mode i just inquire a general
question committee
oh all i'm asking is there's an update
if there is an updated fiscal note
because i'm looking at the one that's on
one if there's an updated fiscal note
is that something that's going to impact
our consumers
today i don't want to wait we don't have
to wait for us having the impact
[Music]
my question was with anyone's mind
change
is it mind change or position change
either way with an updated system
right now it's indeterminate so
if no one's mine's going to change then
you know i'm not going to wait for a
potential update
the answer is no i think we can move the
question
it can't be emotional seeing no
seeing no further
seeing no further hand is raised uh i
don't have the cameras on i hope so
the matter will now be put to question
if you're in support of the motion to
retain
[Music]
physical note can be taken up when we
have the retain bill
at this time the third one i'll call the
roll
vice chairman welch yeah
representative bob green yes
representative hopper
yes representative dennis green
yes representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true
yay representative pratt yes
representative marston yeah the clerk
votes yes
representative harry gathwright yes
representative pantalakis
yes representative massimo
yes representative gordon a
yes representative muse
yes representative
yes representative andrew bolden yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley yes
chairman chair votes yes mr chair the
vote is 21 yay 0
by going to 21 years zero maze the
ocean kane's past the sub came
uh representative andrew luck because it
seemed that you were interested in being
on sits upgraded
[Music]
yes
yeah i'll throw my name uh out there if
you if you need someone or if there's
others who want to do it i'll step down
but just saying i'm
let me ask this if you wish to didn't
representative is interested in being on
yes
mr chairman may ask a question of you
when at the appropriate time
you may be recognized for a question
thank you would it be
appropriate to hold a full committee
session of some kind because it seems
like there's a lot of interest
and interest in getting it to a place we
can support
and i don't recall seeing this many
hands for any subcommittees last week
so you should you're not sitting in the
room so
[Music]
it's a little more of a quieter feel
from where i'm sitting
but uh just because you're not appointed
to something doesn't mean you can't
you can't participate in hearing the
subcommittee makes any different
recommendation
there's no voting you know there's no
vote to uh
for that member as a member of the
subject but
anyone can sit in on the here and you
can sit in the room whether it's on zoom
whatever whatever it is there's no
research on it so
when i'm putting numbers on it it's
because those members are going to have
it
obviously you're going to have to
work on each other let me just go
through
we'll add representative that's what
[Music]
i can read it the others are all gone
i'll make sure you get it and uh
represent well you will be going chair
that's updated
i need lara's
[Laughter]
whatever just putting it to you would
you like to chair it or not i'll do it
you know i'll just soon do it
i didn't we could always appoint
representative burke
[Music]
of that subcommittee
okay at this time we're going to close
the executive session
on senate bill 92
there's been one so senate bill excuse
me house bill 296
passed this committee
and amended in the senate they made a
minor change to it
however it had to do with
and what they what was changed was one
line where
the house building said either it was
done with the intent to harass
[Music]
if you can hanoi me what line that works
once you get it because i don't have my
i'm 14.
so the this the senate amendment removes
returns annoy from
uh uh um two a
is is the section uh i tell them
i have to keep going back to the
amendment
if they have the old one because i know
we didn't bring out paperwork
he or she sends by electronic an
unsolicited
intimate image depicting sexually
explicit conduct
the recipient with the intent to harass
the noise
or alarm the recipient
so that part is what that's the language
that's been passed in the house
the word alarm or noise has been
uh removed that's
one part
[Music]
here
so there is some concern
that's the only change that i i see in
there's some concern about that how
impacted the
sex offender registered depending on the
effects
so it's been this has been brought my
attention by one of the staples
by changing it undermines or reduces the
i i like the original language better
i'm not clear why it was amended to
not include annoy or alarm
if you look at the definition of
harassment under our rsas
it includes annoying or alarming
behavior
but i suppose that being annoying or
alarming doesn't necessarily necessarily
have to rise harass
so it seems to take it this is where i
interpret it narrows the applications
where the point being is that someone's
sending an unsolicited
we all can be on the receiving end of
that and some of us may be
considered some of this may be alarmed
by someone who do that
they can be different levels from the
person
right i'm not clear why they
[Music]
thank you mr chair in another world at a
different time
whenever goals like this came over in
other committees
we did a line-by-line change as
committee
researcher committee flight
i'm not saying that you missed anything
it's always nice to be able to see these
bills
side by side line by line
so they show what the changes are
in in fairness to our canadian assistant
he did send that to me and i just
so in fairness the advance of brad
agreement he did send that to the chair
of the committee
okay and the chairs just located that in
his email
question of the chair alright guys
thank you mr chairman so they made the
change to take it out
in essence they're sending it back to us
well and a committee conference that's
that's the challenge so the two the two
notations i i'll just read this
so the senate version replaced he or she
with the person
and the senate version also removes that
the person sending the image may
have the intent to annoy or alarm the
recipient the senator would need to have
the intent to harass the recipient so
that narrows it but then also changes
roman numeral three so the senate
version keeps the penalty for
the first offense and subsequent offense
the same
the senate version also adds the person
must have been convicted at the time
the subsequent attack or to be guilty
so
in order to have it to be a subsequent
fence you need a conviction that's
standard you know in the wall already so
i don't know that
fixed anything that's not already wrong
i mentioned before
you have to get charged with drunk
driving three times for three days
they're all going to be first offenses
if you don't have a prior position
so
i believe the original bill that we
passed
it would be the penalty would go up
for a second subsequent offense this is
completely sent
back to the committee so under our bill
is the first offense is a violation i
[Music]
from the policy as much as it's uh
clarifying that but you can't it's
already the law
you can't be charged with something
defense about prior conditions you have
to prove
the prior conditions
i'm not sure why that was done but that
could be discussed in
the media problems as well is that true
do we have uh any uh bills coming back
from the senate
the wise man once said you should always
hold on to one committee
bill okay we need to do massive changes
on something else
is this the one maybe we need well
it was there was another one that we had
an issue with stash limitations and i'll
tell you what that bill was
we discussed that it was involving um
crimes against a minor
that one i believe we made six years
the senate reduces to three i think the
consensus of the committee was
that we all wanted six so we would be
having
at least i'm gonna ask that the
committee of congress would be done on
that a lot i just want to get you the
so we passed this that's with the
tolling of the stats limitations was six
six years after the 18th birthday for
the alleged
victim the senate reduced that for three
years
i like the six years better i i wouldn't
want to build a
lot i think three's better than nothing
but i still
i think six years is sufficient i mean
you can't even buy cigarettes when we
i think the other sections is clarifying
that is the law
already yeah it's more clarification
purposes
but that's the major change i
read from the definition of harassment
just
i was not convinced the change was
necessary and so much as it's at least
because i don't think that necessarily
annoying or alarming amounts to
harassment but
it's part of the definition of
harassment
if you are harassing someone you're
annoying or alarming that that's hard
harassment is a little bit more
all right again
anthologists
and uh why not on a positive note
congratulations on hospital 286.
this was recently signed into law i
believe that's the first bill out of the
committee this year that's been signed
the law so you get the price
there's no official uh prize for that
but whatever it is
you got it i just um thank you chair
and thank you members of the committee
it was
obviously a very bipartisan effort since
we couldn't have gotten it that far
without um working
together on that so um
i can't wait to see what comes out of
that thanks for everyone's
commitment to that thanks chair
representative i just
wanted to ask the question yes
is it all right with you if i start
send senate bill 92 after september
uh say after 15th
do you have the hearings well i'm not
i'm not sure when the subcommittee is
going to be able to meet
again that's something i would have to
consult with the speaker's office on i
while we're while every well people are
participating members of disney remotely
these only limited times so we're not
going to meet this is the last meeting
we're going to have
we don't have we exact every bill that's
been brought to us we're not holding
anything
so it's up to the chairs of those
subcommittees to figure out when they
can
make the schedule so i just don't know
when that that can be done
if everyone meets in person would make
it easier
but i again i don't
i'm not sure what that's that's up to
the members of the community
something concerned generally we don't
meet during july and august
july and august so
too
[Music]
yeah so i i know everyone wants to was
so eager to work on senate bill 92 so
i'm
appreciative of wanting to uh get
started yeah i thought that usually
comes from the speaker also
but he tells people when they may stop
and he's 51 years old so i want you to
know that if you read it online
you know it's true it's the wrong
demonstration
i i didn't get dennis anything would you
like to swap
before do any members have any other
questions or comments
can you read me one more time what the
old one says
the original version that passed in the
house
says any person who violates this
provision of this sex shall be guilty of
a violation for the first offense
in a misdemeanor for a second or
subsequent
the senate version says any person who
violates the provisions of this section
shall be guilty of a violation for the
first offense
in the misdemeanor for the second
or subsequent offense if the court finds
that the person has previously been
convicted
of a violation of this section at the
time of
of the subsequent advocates so the
senate
language is clarifying that in order to
have a subsequent offense
would be considered a second more
subsequent offense you must have
already been convicted of the act at the
time
[Music]
the second assumption events occurred
that's my interesting way to live up
not to rehash 90 senate bill 92 but i
brought the trump driving situation
because that five number one who charged
five offenses were all
into the first offenses that's because
there's never been a conviction
so i i understand a lot without the fire
it could be written that way
it doesn't change the operation of it
it's a lot of substance without a prior
conviction yeah
but that's okay that's right the
difference
[Music]
can write it there it is it's going to
be in the law and i don't know if you
every time we draft the provision as a
subsequent offense or a second third
fourth defense must be addressed
you must have been already convicted i
mean it sounds like a lot of
i think you weren't going there anyway i
will be
uh moving for uh media conferences there
i don't believe there's any other bills
out there that we haven't discussed in
thank you everyone that's it that
finishes year one for us